ici nous allons y entrer
salut mon nom est l'appel de Sam Sam Corbett
je ne pense tout simplement pas que cela vaut la peine d'
opérer dans ce domaine je n'ai pas réussi
à être une seule personne nous interrompons ce
programme Rita je ne comprends pas ce qui se
passe
peut  'attends de te voir bonjour qui est-ce
le nom du tueur est Sam je répète le
nom du tueur ce tueur dont tu
parles il assassine des familles tu le
trouve garçon oh garçon nous allons lui montrer quelle vraie
douleur
dureena
ouais je ne peux pas croire  ceci dit dans
tout cet endroit je n'ai tué personne
nous avons maintenant Rita
je ne connais pas cet homme